bonsoir votre réaction sur votre
score et bien écoutez ce soir je ferai
plusieurs constats c'està-dire que je ne
peux pas être heureux du score de ma
famille politique UMP qui n'est pas à la
hauteur de mes espérances mais je ferai
également un autre constat si vous
voulez c'est que le score réalisé par le
maire signe un désaveux des neers
sois alors je vous explique c'estàdire
que le maire précédent avait
avait réalisé un score de 40 % sans
écologie les ver et là nous avons un
score de 36 et quelques pour avec
écologie de ver donc nous avons une BAE
de 13 points pour le Parti socialiste ce
qui signe donc un désaveux des ne sois
de la politique menée depuis 43 ans dans
cette ville question d'rico ah alors ce
sera moi oui Philippe Cordier évidemment
cette question avant le le deème tour
c'est est-ce que vous allez enfin vous
entendre avec la tête de liste UD
Guillaume Maillard pour ce ce deè tour à
never ben écoutez je pense que
effectivement nous nous sommes obligés
de toute façon de nous entendre avec
l'UDI et que au deuxème tour nos deux
listes qui sont des familles politiques
très
proches quand même on ne sent pas
d'enthousiasme ah si si si un grand un
grand mais si si si un grand
enthousiasme de ma part je pense que
nous n'avons d'abord pas le choix et
nous allons nous unir pour pour sortir
cette ville du du du Parti socialiste et
pourquoi pas d' d'autres d'autres unions
nous sommes ouverts à tout voilà